das ist fast ein spiegelbild aus dem
märz die ängste sind in jedem fall da
weil natürlich auch unseren mitarbeitern
bewusst ist dass wir diesen einen
lockten schon gehabt haben
das heißt wir haben uns doch gerade
wieder ein bisschen berappelt im sommer
alle hatten ein gutes gefühl war ein
guter dinge dass wir das jetzt nur
wieder durchstarten können waren jetzt
vielleicht auch nicht so gut darauf
vorbereitet dass uns jetzt wieder so
hart zuschlägt ängste sind da und alle
sind wirklich wissbegierig und wollen
wissen wie es weitergeht sind gespannt
auf die information aus der politik die
uns jetzt zuteil werden und sind weiter
gespannt trotz hat sich ihre stimmung ja
auch von gestern abend als wir hier
waren die live schalte hier gestern
abend um 18 uhr gemacht haben bis jetzt
gerade nachdem klar war dass es
eventuell 75 prozent an geld dann aus
dem jahr 2009 10 gibt noch mal geändert
was ist dadurch ihren kopf gegangen
können sie sich da eventuell noch ein
bisschen besser mit retten mit dem geld
ja so wenn das wirklich stimmen sollte
das müssen wir auch erst mal noch ein
bisschen prüfen was da im prinzip uns
zuteil werden soll
das ist am anfang auch immer wie bei der
soforthilfe zu anfang auch so leicht
dahingesagt und dann sind da gewisse
voraussetzungen die wir erfüllen müssen
wenn es so ist wäre es eine riesengroße
erleichterung für uns weil ich gerade in
unserem bereich in unserer branche an
unsere mitarbeiter denke die müssen gut
durch die zeit kommen sie haben gerade
erwähnt da ist schon die angst da wie
zahle ich überhaupt noch meine miete mit
dem kurzarbeitergeld und dem fehlenden
trinkgeld und mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schaue ich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren